apparently we've gone Live on YouTube so
welcome everyone
to welcome everyone to today's external
overie committee this work yeah bring
it
um today Wednesday 1st November
2023 um thank you everyone coming if
you're watching on
YouTube have we got any apologies for
absence yes chair we've had apologies
from councelor Thomas and councelor lell
is substituting um we've had apologies
from councelor bar and councel hon is
substituting excellent thank
you I information of the minutes of the
meeting held on 13th of September
please take Page by page page one page
two page
three page four page five page six page
seven page
eight I have some minutes
counc counc SMI second all in favor
and
dat and
exensions public participation we don't
have
any AC list this is quite long because
we had quite a few actions last
me so the first one it's about the North
District hosal site and the letters that
we sent the MP regarding that we have
had a response which has been circulated
to all members and i' circulated again
to
B everyone happy to
take can I ask a question on
that I
see concern from I the member of the
public about the um Easter water or well
the bus service in general actually um
and East water in particular uh has
anything be done about that because um I
thought it would be on the acting to
call them
in I think
councilor
was coun you got I just to raise the the
problems that people are having the bu
services in
decision I wasn't sure where the right
sorry I've never been to one of these
I'm not sure where the right place I
know issu and we refer back to hatok but
I think that was separate that was more
the
potholes yes yeah so um Tom bstone
forwarded on those contact details for
hatok to counselor Thomas at the
following the last meeting but I suppose
the bus services would be separate from
[Music]
h me yeah so we could have that as an
action I I was going to suggest that we
actually ask stage code which is the one
that needs the water anyway um we've had
we've had an email from a very concerned
elderly person needs the water and they
say that nobody knows where the buses
are going to now there's the they
haven't got a schedule of of or a Tim
table of any kind and people are totally
confused apparently they all start from
Tes go e the water but it's difficult to
tell whether they're going upwards
towards Easter water or going down back
into town and covering their other Roots
so they say everybody over there who
wishes the buses and I know quite a few
people who do are quite confused really
anxious and they don't know what's going
on and of course they W Used buses they
reported taxes many of them have got
their eome and of course then St coach
have that as an excuse to get rid of
them so I do think we should get hold of
them
Sher and ask them to come in and explain
themselves because it's a bit like
closing the um the ticket offices at the
railway station know they've done this
albitar thing um and but they haven't
consulted people in any way and it
certainly isn't customer friendly what
we're
doing I would just like that and that
I've been speaking with someone only
this evening and they were very
concerned about the Route 75 and Route
15s and saying that the The Roots have
changed the number of way you can get on
and off has changed um I mean I can
slightly understand Roots have changed
although I'm not justifying them but
when um you know the bu is still going
along but the BL stops to get off and
off on leaving people standed and
walking up hills who can't necessarily
walk up hill it's very hard to really
understand what's going on it's
something that we could The Joint well
imagine that they'd be experiencing
similar issu yeah and and and they've
cut services so that the gaps between
the one that the children are catching
the the um the B to exit one is now only
once every three hours so if a child
misses the bus either going or coming
from from college or or school they you
it's a huge weightly this time of year
you know if you miss the 3:00 and the
next one 6:00 long time be hanging about
in the dark if you're a child but you
well I mean I don't know the exact time
of where they'd be getting
up: you I mean but the Gap the three-
hour gap is is enormous um and far too
much for one of those kind of
um kind of services where you know
children are are trying to get to
college and school I mean you both ends
of the SCH I mean nobody likes not
having a decent service but for the
elderly that are faced with walks that
aren't practicable for them to do and
for young people not getting where they
need to be safely it's a matter of Brave
concern I think happy it to the
action pleas propose that
[Music]
thank don't know if we need to vote on
it think that's is that you
noing to Centric all the time it cracks
me up
councel bronos the counc second thank
you the next one was looking into the
bite siiz training with the police we
still haven't had our community safety
Parn meeting but I think there are plans
for that to be held on the 30th of
November is that right car
but that's still being
agre yeah that's correct I was going to
um yeah so um yet to be confirmed with
Toby D okay so that was where we raised
that so I would say that's complet raise
that me uh the next one is still ongoing
we're trying to organize committees on
denst agriculture
joint um next one is about hat up sent
to council promas
week councelor clerk he sent on
information about the link sent
proposals and we had an email back on
him today still he's sent on to
[Music]
inspector one of the inspectors who will
get back to us for
the um
[Music]
CRA letter around as well Z DCC um and
our MP about the link Center
proposals and our support as a result of
that meeting
yes i' got your email about the
petition um and I thought I interpreted
that that you thought it was going to
come up at full Council and number was
that not the case you seem to be saying
in your email that you contacted um the
chair councilor bushby and he that it
would be come up as a sort of Emery
emotion but he was comping with it yeah
I contacted him it didn't happen and I
was unfortunately unable to the me as
well no problem about that but what
happened why didn't it come through I
was told that it wasn't raised because
they didn't have the full wording of the
petition so it will be put formally on
the agenda for
December that's right yeah wasn't in
front of full Council so
they can didn't know what they would be
agreeing to so it's going to be um as an
agenda item for to come back so that
members can consider the wording of
petition and and whether they support
are happy to support that
petition yeah yeah I'm sorry I contacted
the chair and I assumed it was coming
forward at that meeting but that's not
what happened but it will be properly on
the December
meeting um what else is next on yeah
that's um I haven't been given a date of
when Sir Jeffrey Cox will meet at the
link Center Council mckinness um I can
follow that up again that he it has been
raised with him um and councelor hackit
is raising the issue of the link centers
at the police and crime panel
meeting councelor Hudson is the next one
have you spoken with the leader um
regarding provision
in that was AC counil of shepher is here
as we have had conversations about this
um and the alternative provision that is
being offered I believe through the
youth center yes um but it's not the
same as the link center used to be um so
we are still
awaiting it's not on this
uh adult scrutiny
meeting uh which is next week um there's
no report on that particular issue
there's tin reports on the
scrutiny um agenda but nothing to do
with the link center but uh I will again
emphasize the fact that we cannot make
judgments about existing link centers if
we haven't reinstated a referral system
because the numbers they're going to be
looking at are not reflective of the
need within the community if you turn
off the access to them um by not
allowing referrals to be made you're not
going to get a true picture so that is
my key sort of platform at the moment to
inform that report
um I'm just looking at this and I I do
apologize and what options are being
considered for the building where the
link center was housed and councelor
shepher well there is a meeting
hopefully taking place next week between
myself pen James and John Hen who um
runs the youth center and uh it's going
to be a meeting we're gonna see what the
next plan of action is going to
be doing the chair um counc Hudson um
what's the newent at Hy like is it very
well ended um is it once a week what's
the situation if it's if there's an idea
that it can be used for um the mental
health um problems as
well as a youth center it's very well
attended right as a uh alternative to a
link center it's
not there's it's Peaks and troughs
basically from what I understand but um
sign posting is a bit of an issue in Hwy
but again at this meeting I'm hopeing
find that more okay well as an ex youth
leader who worked in a youth club for
quite a few years um they can be very
Lively places um they're great but you
know kids being kids I really don't
think that's an appropriate venue people
who have mental health problems the new
center and the provision for the link
the two separate times Well I agre
separate times but my experience at new
club I worked in the kids were always
hanging about there all the time whether
it was the club was in situ or not so I
think you know it obviously isn't the
ideal thing to have a mental health um
Center and H and I did work in the need
Center as well when I was um involved
with the mental health charity um where
you need quiet a relaxed
atmosphere um a lot of um calm and
helpful situation for people who
sometimes have very serious problems
considering we have the higher than
average self harm and the higher than
average suicide right and I'm quoting
from the figure in here um we really
should be looking for a place that
fulfill those attributes and I don't
think the new center probably is the
place unless it's so big that you can
differentiate between two I would say
completely agree if the idea would be to
use the building rather C was use that
again as a link censor completely
agree counc um I think the best thing is
to ask councelor James and councelor
sheer when theyve had this next meeting
to actually report and I note uh
councilor Brenton's comments
about maybe the two groups not being
compatible um but it's just how they
actually work that and it may well be
that they can have separate uh sessions
and that they don't get the interaction
with the young people we must remember
too young people have mental health
issues as well so uh you know for them
it might be a really good place to be so
um and I think thinking back from the
meeting that we had it was concerns over
um mental health professionals but
because it's a voluntary type service
rather than the
paid how much how much input they're
getting from um a professional service
so I think the best person to actually
ask is um for councelor Shephard and uh
councelor James to actually report to
this committee because the concerns were
we was um Advocate um service for
complex I hold up my hand and say I I
did say this week to councelor James
that I really ought to go down and visit
the youth center because it's on the
youth provision side of things something
I'm really quite interested in um Madam
chair in my person I'm am substituting
for is arrive sorry my late arrival I
don't know what the process is now do I
into the background or be home if
you I'm counselor
I don't know what the well you if you
substitute you're here as opposed not
that councel back can't be here but yeah
you are councelor back for tonight
you'll be voting but sorry coun sorry we
can't switch halfway through the
meeting you're very
[Music]
welcome thank you I think that's
the um
Declaration of Interest members of
Interest should refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interest when item is considered
agreement of agenda it part one and two
there's no part two so that's easy seven
urgent matters brought forward with of
the chair no one's raised' already about
sa
Co that one
um oh just an update on the mobile
Library campaign um if the fin decision
being made next week by De County
council's cabinet Wednesday the 8 of
November um and also I had a phone call
from someone she actually works at a
dentist which we know is in crisis but
she brought up and I do know it's an
issue with having young children myself
a child care
crisis um and the lack of child minders
and how are people expected to get to
work when there are no child minders to
get their children to school or to
Nursery it's and I think it's especially
PE in rural areas where we don't have
that wraparound hair in the local
Village School and it's have it's a real
it is a child care crisis the retirement
age is increasing so grandparents are
less able to um to help out or they
might not always be available they might
not live nearby um and the government is
introducing more free child care and in
the coming years um nine month from nine
months old children again have free
child care but there's already a crisis
now so I don't I feel like it's
something that's already impacting us
but it's going to have an even bigger
impact when this these three hours come
in and I just wanted to bring it up
tonight um and Petro given their
apologies this evening so if they come
back at a later date maybe that's
something we can r with them as well I
don't know if anyone's got any thoughts
on who else we could speak to about
[Music]
this any any thoughts it's a real tricky
one but it is an issue that affects a
lot of our
residents pick up we can do a bit of
backf finding and get back next week
yeah because I said to this lady who
found me I completely understand I'll go
away have a thing and talk to people and
see what we can do it's difficult as a
district council but we can raise
awareness try and make certain things
happen I think there needs to be higher
pay for child minders I think the issue
of bad um and nurseries and child
minders is off putting people who want
to go into that profession
um well it's just the forgetting that
per you could contact children's Cent
what experiences their clients are
having obviously they're very young
children there they're one to three but
um but they I do know that they used to
in the past have a well a sort of group
of child minders who used to come in to
benefit from training and health and
safety training as well that was
provided so they must be have an ear to
the ground particular issue so they
might be able to give us some theories
on where to go
we funding for our village stoes for the
r around care there obviously some of
the bigger in the towns they offer the
breakfast clubs and the after school
clubs because they've got the larger
numbers and then the a lot of the
Village schools are decreasing in number
because parents are driving them to the
towns to drop them off because they get
that longer longer amount of care so
they can get to work on
time that up
another sure can I just say it might be
worth with some of the schools about
this because they're the very people who
will know the number of people who are
in trouble and they may have a register
of of people who can help it's usually
in the past it's always been done people
just put their heads together and it out
but perhaps the schools might might be
able to or we should perhaps we should
get schools involved in this process
yeah I'll let everyone go away and have
bit more thing come back something coun
not that it's a constructive thing today
but I think the government's made it
even worse with they introducing the
regulations and um that they have done
without sort of thinking that P because
Nursery closing because they can't
afford to stay open meet the
requirements of the government so in in
in a in a situation where they're saying
why aren't we wantable we giving these
fre places they're
also
instigating
a lot of places you just can't AF to
keep
running Catch 22 going on unfortunately
because the regulations surrounding you
know setting up a newy or whatever I
mean I think the numbers are the ones
closing it's quite
frightening um you know the waiting
thing growing and
growing I'm not being very constructive
it's a bit depressing but it has you
know where to move it's all very
wonderful for the government to say you
know we're giving you all this free but
there's got to be a provision and
they're not doing the other the other
bit of it ex unfortunately so I do I do
feel for you completely okay on that
note let's go on to education and
employment in Tor thank you so much for
coming to our meeting we've got oh
should I let you introduce yourselves
yeah certainly that's okay okay good
evening everybody U my name is Peter
morish and and I'm from condition
monitoring Technology Group in sington
and um a little bit I'll explain a
little bit more about me and um our
business and our uh our requirement for
uh bringing in new recruits Skilling up
Skilling people and I would say Madam
chair um the point you made about um
getting child care we recognize is very
important and I knowe the first question
on the uh for this evening was what is
the gender balance for people applying
and getting the part ship I think this
this connection of how we can actually
get um a better gender balance in in our
businesses in torage area is linked to
the point you make about child care so
thanks very much I'll hand over now
Chris you know me uh Chris for economic
manager at T District
Council
w e it uh yeah good evening my name is
Tom Hart general manager Apple door
Shard yeah good evening everyone my name
is Tony Cole I'm the uh apprenti ship
and training manager at app buers and
been there for 30 years now so on and
off for different companies so a little
bit of history of where I've come
from um who do you want to start your
Pres if you could yeah um we were given
a brief really of uh apprenti and
training or education within forage as a
district and for well initially for me I
thought what if I could just start by
explaining to you all what we see our
apprenticeship Journey To Be Where It
Starts where it goes and it travels
through the four years of the program
maybe that can give you an understand
you know where we are and some of the
things some of the issues we have in FA
and will face as we we go through so if
you could be it'll be about 8 minutes so
I'm not going to all you too long but uh
it's only 10
slides so for us uh inspiring
engagements where we start with
apprenticeships it doesn't start from a
job I've in the paper for us it starts
with schools it starts with open
evenings career days things like that
and we're trying to inspire the interest
in stem or steam as it's now being
leaned towards and trying to get people
keen on that part of what we do although
we are a ship Builder fundamentally is
an engineering friend we are structural
steel work engineering company so we do
try and Inspire engagement like I said
local school secondary school colleges
normally about nine months before we
actually look to recruit so we do get
try and get in reasonably early in the
secondary schools normally around
October to to December so now we're
looking at recruiting for next September
so our school fols are going to start in
the next few weeks Baron's already
booked we've got another one at Park as
well in a few weeks later so this is
where we get in gr for and try and
capture the minds of our future
employees uh career spairs employees
open evenings and even targeted specific
engineering groups or classes within
some of the some of the some of the
actual schools and colleges we do Target
years 9 to
12 uh at the moment however I do think
and we believe that the target group
should be lower uh we are looking
already to start looking at Primary
School involvement because it's never
too early to get that Gem of engineering
spark or that little nugget inside
someone's mind early doors so we're
going to start looking at primary
schools in next year's uh recruitment
process so we have looked at like we
said bit ton Park and petrock is
probably our four main schools we visit
uh when it comes to open days and open
evenings uh like I said though we are
looking at schools as well and we do
offer work experience uh last year we
took uh nine work experienced students
throughout last Academic Year I say last
year but this year Academic Year uh from
various schools even as far away as bu
hayen which was quite a surprise when
their name come through in the school
but word of mouth I think is spread and
we got a little bit more interest than I
first
anticipated but then it's something
we've done for years on years before
myself as a 15year old from bford
college I went to the shipyard for work
experience myself so we do believe in
the system of inspiring young
mind I'm going to go through this video
and the S seems already to let me
down which could be my thing hang on a
minute I have turn the TV up
so make sure my volumes up but basically
we created a partnership with petrock
and and their second
year uh media studies
[Music]
students uh wanted
a project so we said well give us a
project that actually looks at
recruiting our apprenticeship so they
spend some time down at the
site and
also also on the college if I don't play
I I'll talk to you about it and
basically just to try and use this video
yeah I'm just wear the
sound because this this was actually
made
[Music]
by hi welcome to the Petro engineering
environment here we study lots of
different courses or you study different
courses um we do our full-time courses
which are transition to T level and
level we also do lots of different
appren ships op friendships start LEL
two which is the engineering Optive
which is what Holland and come on to
fabrication worlding paway then there's
lots of also level three appren so
what's an apprenti why is it different
to full-time education so you go into
Place 80% of the time and then for 20%
have job so that's whether you're in
college
or well we do quite a lot of um School
engagement um certainly with um careers
days and um just visiting the schools
we obviously showcased the island W
Shipyard so what why do you want to do
an apprenti ship um so I did apprenti
when I was young so I was very much an
advocate of apprenti ships I've always
sort of liked doing more Hands-On work
than anything in the classroom or an
office and um it just seemed more fun
and that's a great place to be it's
important for me to be able to go and
get my education um but to be in the
workplace as well and learn their
valuable skills uh so just see like
fit
what we do is we give them freedom to
understand how the whole Yard Works you
can become a fabricator so basically
construction but with metal uh you can
be a welder you can be a maritime
plumber or a maritime mechanical Critter
um which is just basically mechanical
boat and they get experience then in
basically every different trade um from
the shop floor up to um the support uh
function such as engineering everything
that makes a a shipyard run well I mean
the shipyard has been here as long as I
can remember and it's just got such a
Heritage in the community that it's it's
just a nice place to be able to say you
work here and I mean ship has been
around for longer than I can remember
it's just it's a nice craft you know you
see something come together from the
start to finish and when you see a
finished prod you can say I was part of
that I about
that
so yeah
after say hopefully youd like that video
for a start yeah so we try and put that
out as well uh as far as the recruitment
goes it normally goes live in February
and March we start putting the apps out
and encouraging people to start applying
uh the application is normally open for
six weeks and then they have initial
phone call back from R HR department to
discuss with The Apprentice or potential
Apprentice um what are their interests
what are their interests what of Trades
do they think you're interested in and
it's surprising it might be they ask a
silly a silly question you might think
but do you actually want an
apprenticeship unfortunately a lot of
students do get pushed into this Avenue
that they may not be interested in so
you almost have a filter system to say
do you really are you really interested
in this or is this just something you
think I'll have a go out or to try and
do so they have a phone call vhr and
then we have an interview an assessment
daing
June we can give feedback to the
applicants after the end of June and
then the offer Employments normally go
out Rend July or the September intake is
when they normally start with us all
right first week week one so they
started with us in September that's our
newest intake so we've had 19 start in
September as you can see it's a fairly
large group for us uh so they spend
their first week looking at
inductions basically looking at things
like safety in coures we do find safety
manual handling work face F testing all
those things we have to do before we can
even let them look inside the main
building include risk assessment
security passes they the PPE and
eventually we get to the point we take
them for a site
tour there year one like I said in the
video we don't pigeon our apprentices as
soon as they
start uh in the past we've said we'll
take on 10 welders and 10 ship rights 10
Fabricators 10 plumbers and not
everybody enjoys that trade three months
daying the line the appren say this is
for me this is not what I'm really good
at or I don't think I like this and we
didn't have a huge retention record I
think we were sort of averaging about
25% loss over the first year I think
because a lot of our students a lot of
our potential recruits are at an age
where they really don't appreciate what
the job may be until you had a fair
chance to actually try it so really for
us the first year is almost to try
before you buy kind of attitude and give
them chance to settle into the
environment before we start saying when
you're going to do this trade or that
trade but it does Focus around
fabricating and Welding so and for us
doesn't matter what your trade is within
ship building it does involve some
fabricating and Welding doesn't matter
what it is you will do some of that
anymore so it's a good grounding to any
apprenti ship they spent three days in
college and two days on site with us and
spend the first 16 weeks in what we've
got you saw in the video there our
Apprentice Training Center where we
focus on the Practical ship building
skills uh burning welding grinding
marking off lining off all the things we
need every person to have regardless of
what they're doing and then as we said
in Tom said as well they spend the rest
of that first year going around
different departments having a little
taste of what it's like to be in a w
department or the fabricating department
or the pipe
shop and at the end of that first year
we decide what their apprenti is going
to be and what their level three element
is going to look like for the next three
years of their apprenticeship then will
be focused on that particular
trade other experiences we do we
obviously try and get involved where we
can with other things certainly this
year our second year group were're
involved in obviously the so boox Derby
in
and our brand new recruits in fact all
our apprentices all 31 we took them out
uh about two weeks ago I think it was
took a out for an adventure day up at
the Adventure Center in mford uh to try
and what we trying to do because we've
got three year groups we kind of wanted
them all to interact together because
some of the things the year 3s have
already been and done and seeing they
can pass on to the year 2s and and so on
to the year the Year ones that have just
started so included archery High roach D
mountain boarding and even a water
assault course which I understand was
pretty cold this time of year so I think
they're a g getting out the pool on that
day the rest of the years as I've said
before they'll complete their level two
and then move on to their trade specific
level
three and again the main four trades we
are looking at the moment but this is
not the only trades there's other trades
we will look at in the future but is a
mechanical fitter a pipe fitter
fabricator or welder uh we're also
looking at potentially maybe
blacksmithing which is one of the trades
which is not as popular as it used to be
but we want to keep it going within our
own
industry and once they' completed that
then obviously they will join the rest
of the school Workforce and hopefully
create many of the ships for the future
all right any questions
Tony is Tony how long do the
apprenticeships normally last it does it
depend on the trade uh we normally
Target the apprenti shps for four years
um there is with every apprenticeship
there is the what we call a minimum and
a a sort of a maximum time frame it
takes to complete an apprenti they're
not set in stone our level two is on an
average of 18 months to do a level two
and the level three is sort of 20 4 to
36 months so again it depends on their
performance how they get on with it a
lot of factors depending on the of the
actual appren ship we try and Target it
for four years in total can I ask how
many of them stay after that is there is
is there well funny enough that was one
of the questions about retention
unfortunately we're not in a position
yet to answer that one because which is
a good thing I think no one's actually
finished so we' only got three year
groups at the moment so
our our oldest apprentices have just
entered their third year so
realistically they got at least another
18 months to go hopefully our retention
will be great that's what we're aing for
what we can say is our retention of the
apprentices has been really good we've
lost one Apprentice in three years in
three years
so 32 that would have been there yeah 31
now I mean what what's quite remarkable
is in the first year of opening we
we uh advertised for 10
apprentices we got only four
applications um in the second year we
advertised for
15 and we only got seven
applications we' taken them all we took
the first four we took the the second
year seven and then in the third year
just gone we advertised for 20 and we
got over 35 applications
so it's really heartening to see that
you know I think with the confidence
building with Holland the wolf and the
and the work in the pipeline now that's
kind of known to most people it you know
that that trend is is is building
upwards and um hopefully you know we we
actually have to discuss next week on
the numbers of apprentices we're going
to take for um
um we we can't obviously because we have
to Mentor them and you know teach them
and we have to put them under the the
eyes of our experienced Workforce we
can't have too many but obviously the
the year 3es will be pretty much
finished I would say when they turn they
will take on more responsibity newer
ones as they go through responsibility
so will be development yeah cycle
really that's really interesting to hear
I appreciate that this is a new project
to some extent and Al we've had
apprenticeship course there was one at
the end of 2009 to
2010 um that heavily involved the trade
unions as well and that was a very
successful program at the time um but go
by the wayside um uh during the ear
years of the of the um join government
um if you have a situation where you
you've got a successful Apprentice who
you can see is very enthusiastic and
Keen um is there any means by which
possibly if they don't specifically want
to be a ship Builder and obviously this
appr ship is ship building specific but
you can detect that they have skills
let's say I don't know civil engineering
something like like that would you be
able to point them in another direction
or is it very much tunneled into either
ship buing or Harland and what I can
understand why it would be but I can
think of a situation where you get a
very enthusiastic young person who's
might develop great skills that they
might not all be ship building specific
and you might see they have great
potential in another area can you coope
with that can you do something with it
um the the actual College section of
them your appren ship is quite prescri
it's prescriptive it's it's designed for
us yeah the units we cover the Fabrica
welding elements are specific to the
needs of our company however that's
saying that the portfolio is very
flexible and a portfolio within the
apprenticeship although it may fit a
certain standard or a certain certain
framework if we needed a person within a
different role and they had skills
within that role and it still supported
our
company the apprenticeship can be
tailored around the mvq or the portfolio
section to suit a different
route that makes sense or the other
option I think would be and Petro would
probably agree if they were here as well
Petro could then look at their own other
departments and say look this one's in
engineering but possibly it could be a
better suited in that role have your
employers or apprenti ships running and
there could be a move there is skills
transferable between obviously if a
young to goes to a university and they
they go for one specific course they can
change to another one if they feel are
not suited but they're still maybe a
genius but they're not suited to that
particular role um so you're saying that
you can the same thing can happen within
the appren they're not tied in it's
either this or failure situation oh no
no no no there would be I say a lot
obviously other people who's got
apprenti ship programs but apprenti
Frameworks and standards have a large
chunk which what we call mandatory
mandatory elements they have to do and
they are very similar certainly ACR
construction engineering traits uh the
first three units of any mandatory
apprenticeship are pretty much identical
it's conss it's it's drawings its
Communications that part is transferable
and in fact every Apprentice or every
potential Apprentice must go through a
skill scan before they start an
apprenticeship because if they've
already got skills that will be taught
there's almost it's someone already said
that this person's further forward than
they would be in comparison to somebody
else so skills are transferable I know
skill scans can be done for different
appren ships in different organizations
different that sounds great can I there
also just to add on to that I mean not
every single Apprentice you know they'll
go through their training on the shop
floor because they need that in-depth
understanding how how to build
ships but they may be suited for uh
engineering or project controls
planning um procurement there is any
number of different professions inside
the ship building industry not just on
the shop block so which to be quite
honest that's transferable skills in in
other sectors as well so yeah thanks
Council Smith thank you um I think you
said it was at the end of the second
year you decided the decision was made
how they progressed into the third year
is that decision based on their aptitude
or is it based on your requirements in
other words do you have a need for
welders rather than something else so we
look at what the business needs are and
as as as wonderful as we want to try and
do when it comes to planning and
foreseeing work uh I couldn't tell you
no what I'm going to need in five years
time uh so really we look at what the
business needs are and if it's 10
welders four ship rides four plumbers
and six Fitters that's what's on the
table
and what we ask The Apprentice to do
based upon their tals when they've done
their rotor their experiences what is
your first choice what's your second
choice and what's your third choice if
if there was no if there was no problem
at all and you could pick your first
choice what would it be from that based
on their performance throughout the year
things like time attendance time keeping
attitude all those performance issues
will be taken into account and we try
and give them their first choice and
also if not their second choice the way
we try and do it thank you based on the
business thank
you yeah um little film I saw LCA there
just now I KN one or
two yeah yeah um but basically uh it's
great that you're bringing on these
youngsters and you doing the
apprenticeship but you need to be a busy
yard to be able to do this and have you
got the work coming on have you got
enough you know Fitters and that coming
on you know can you get them into this
area if you do do a lot more work I mean
that's the big question because you know
it's a little OD but you've got a hell
of a mess to pick up and tidy up is it
ready yet yes it's ready it is fully
operational it is um there are lots of
answers to that question there is and
I'm
just sifting through where to start so
let pipeline of work yes there is um we
right now we are busy um we've been
pretty busy this year in fact maxed out
with the people that we've
got
um we've just picked up another contract
uh this week which we've signed and
that'll be a fabrication
project um and we've got the
Regeneration of the mine hunter which is
started last year um and is is still
going on I it started earlier this year
yeah um and we'll finish basically next
year
um
so yes there is work and there's also
the fleet solid support which is the
construction of three large RFA ships um
and that will start
in March
so we do have quite a healthy
pipeline uh of work and where we are at
the moment with employees we're up to
about
185 at the
moment which is
considering two years ago we were only
at probably about 40 is is is not bad
going
um we will need to buy 25 be up to about
the 300 350 Mark so there is that need
for more
people the trades which we find very
difficult to recruit and get is our
mechanics mechanical guys that's
probably the
hardest um which we luckily got a couple
of have got mechanical biased or bent
you know they that's where the route
they want to go down
um
so you know there there is still at the
moment we we definitely have room for
more apprentices coming in certainly
move on next year and I take it you're
fairly flexible because you like the
mine um sweeper Bo I mean obviously
that's not a steel hole is it so you've
got to be a nonmetal it's it's all well
we've got even Fabricators working on it
and welders working on it you know you
know
fairly agile exactly and that that's I
would say the huge positive with apple
door Shipyard and with the people that
work there is they will turn their hand
to anything so you know if if there not
there's no demarcation there between
trades pretty much they will turn the
hand to everything we've had welders
with paint brushes you know even Tiding
up the yard because everybody the yard
belongs to us all every worker that
works there it belongs to them and
that's that's the way we we we operate
want people to be proud of where they
work um
so the work is there we need more
people um and we need to train more
people
because you know there is an abundance
of skilled people in there out there so
you you want more housing for more
people to live more housing you know
it's gonna ultimately it stimulates the
whole
region and is your site big enough oh
yeah well you go back you know 10 years
you know there there was 450 people
caught working in the art up to 650 and
then actually flexing up to a thousand
people with subcontractors well I know
most of the old boys like margin S as my
neighbor and you know the Elder he gets
some more work he
did so you know yeah there is a bright
future um um in fact actually we today
I've had a one of the um ministers
visiting the
yard um I took him around and you know
again they they're so surprised at how
quite big the yard is and what it can
do
um is really good well
thanks thank you um I just wondering
about exam results because you mentioned
that briefly is set and what happens if
yeah there is there is a small stumbling
block potentionally with the exam
results obviously exam results tend to
come out late in the year as far as for
us recruitment we want to start in
September the exam results normally come
in two weeks before or three weeks
before uh we do aim for a minimum exam
result standard uh we do look at 4G CES
or what they called uh C's that used to
be grade C or
now in the modern scoring system for
however for the right apprentice and the
right setting and the right environment
the college support with functional
skills math and English so it doesn't
necessarily if they get their exam
result sorry we don't want you uh there
is an element of potential for them to
continue to study Master English at
College while still doing their appren
flexibility is flexibility uh yeah
within we within within Norm we it's
historically and
people may or disagree with me on this
but the shipyard was not the employer of
choice if you're academically strong
okay uh I know my age group certainly
when I left Ben College most of my
friends that went down there uh they
weren't the ones that were at the front
of the class with the hand up they were
the ones at the back um but that
stereotype is gone now we want to aim
higher we want to increase our level of
uh achievment and the standard we're
aiming for is a minimum three as far as
our appr ships go and to do that we have
to have that slightly higher academic
level at gcsc unfortunately to get to
that next level of three but there's
more than one way of doing it we don't
just rely on uh the college full
apprenticeship we do art apprenticeships
uh We've even looked at before ad
upskilling so rather than taking an
apprentice on we take a a skilled
employee from even other sectors and
retrain them and they're an adult
apprenticeship scheme they'll do a
portfolio they won't do the college
attendance but do a portfolio only and
we can sort
of well we've got one L took on he
domestic
plumber wonderful domestic plumber but
ship pipe fitting is a bit of a world
difference to domestic Plumbing but the
basic skills he has is a great grounding
so we took him on as an adult upskill
and then we'll just do a portfolio based
on the chip building element for him to
almost UPC really we call it so that's I
think where we mentioned the numbers we
are trying to get to it's not all going
to be appr friendships we know that but
there will be out upskilling so we'll
bring people in on other trades like
grinding or laboring and if they work
out to be good employees will then
afford the time and effort to train them
to be loaders or Fabricators as an adult
rather than as a
prins so what's your aim for how many
penes and upill like for the future how
many do Z obviously increasing and
we
well yeah magic number we a to be well
we will be I Believe by January February
next year will be past the 200 Mark and
I we need to within another year we need
to be up another 100
minimum so by by really beginning of 25
prior to starting the FSS we need to be
yeah 300 minimum strong
um
so
yeah Council Pennington thank you thank
you your report Tony um um it goes
follows on the question that our
chairman was asking and it's about the
qualifications and I'm always interested
in term apprenticeships and our
education system has been in love with a
levels and then need okay and if you
look at the schools you're catching and
looking to put your name to I think
they're averaging about 55% that are
between a and C at GCSE for five levels
if I remember right the figures great
torington and the two BARC schools um
and situation there and you're looking
you know for four ades yeah you haven't
got a very wide pool to choose from have
you that's the pressure point I want to
I think well given that if they get p a
disease they are going to naturally go
on to a level and well I would disagree
we we have one of our sorry to disagree
but one of our previous apprentices
actually came to the yard with four a
levels a star M and nine GCS a star yeah
okay and was a pipe F right brilliant he
chose he chose that route rather than
rather than University so I think
academic level not necessarily automatic
okay now what I'm trying to check is I
got three sons okay and the first one
went into a modern apprenticeship I
shall say was industry but he was
promised that be work in undergrad at
University if you go here right and then
these two brothers went through the a
level course and went to University and
they came back and the Su course Strang
North Southern College and they were
earning more in their sandwich year when
they were on University than what he was
when he he qualifi from Mod
apprenticeship so he went off to
University and said thank you very much
modern apprenticeship now you're
competed against your your more academic
students from that have you got a unique
selling point that sells to attract
those students
in in short I think yes um okay and it's
unfortunately it comes down to the the
financial element so at the end of the
four-year period yeah what would the
apprenticeship qualification be worth
and I hate to say it in Academia terms
but I don't like that
measure if you had a parable a level
three friendship and you agree disree
it's sort of pitched at three a levels
right that's a similar points value
system for an apprenticeship a modern
level three apprenticeship is there
three a levels yeah so if they were want
they did want to go on to a university
after an apprenti which is quite
possible their points value would be
probably equivalent to that there a
transferable option that people do
apprentices then still go back to
University thank you very much because
it is comparable I'm not saying the
points is roughly about
three thank you very much it's it's good
and obviously it go the other way as
well we do encourage the other way as
well we don't I appreciate that because
we have a pool I think we have over
2,000 um claimants of Universal Credit
that are in work yeah um if they're in
on Universal Credit you probably paying
a higher wage and I wondered if you
could actually take on a cred mature
apprentices rather than just those out
out of
school not demonstr we we do I'm sure
you do as well yeah we do yeah you do
that as well absolutely yeah good so
that is another opportunity there for
people on torage who are working to
raise their income really successful
people come in from different different
careers and and cheap really good
positions with within our business I
think it's IL misconception and apprenti
ship is at 16 that's necessar about that
in a
minute say for us
what we try and do because of that one
issue I know we're going to come on to a
little bit more year one uh we met one
of our applicants a young lady she was
38 and we really liked her we thought
this person is special there's something
unique here but uh traditional
apprenticeship
salaries the government minimum uh
salary for an apprentice for the first
year is quite low and if we'd have
offered that money at that rate she she
would have had to have said no
financially for that person in their
life situation it wasn't enough so we
thought well rather than not or lose
this potential
person we upped our salary for an
apprentice to make it feasible for her
just to actually join us it actually
worth her while rather than being on
credits or whatever other benefits
potentially she might have been entitled
to we made it financially worth our
while to come to us instead it's
probably going to be a legacy that's
going to catch us eventually but our
apprenticeship rate is equal to the
national minimum wage so but she loves
it there she's
year she's a fabricator she's just
graduated and she's just got a
certificate and she yeah she L it yeah
and a completely different life to where
she was or where she aspired to be
before so a complete retraining cycle
really thank you thank
you P come in there yeah that's that's
fine yeah know of course thanks very
much Tony really interesting to hear
what you guys are doing at Holland and
wolf and I think it's really great for
our area that this is this is happening
so um let me introduce myself um so I'm
I'm Peter morish and um local lad um
grew up in the area uh on a small dairy
farm just outside of BN and I was lucky
my dading carries me when I was younger
to go after my passion for technology so
at 16 I joined uh small engineering
company which is now condition
monitoring group um I be lucky I've had
a rewarding career ever since that time
and to be honest in our family the
thought you know doing anything other
than going straight into work it was you
had to go and get a job it was wasn't
about going to college you go and do a
job um when I joined condition
monitoring Technology Group cmtg we're a
team of six uh and we were focused on
electronics for the energy sector uh but
from our torington base and we' grown
and we now employ 140 people uh with 85
of those people working in torington in
in high schill wellp paid jobs and we
produce systems that monitor vibrations
in helicopters and turbines we analyze
data um this is important because it's
all about the maintenance of these
machines and we can hopefully make them
run safer and and last longer our
customers are worldwide uh this includes
nuclear power stations military
helicopter fleets and air ambulances so
quite a good story it's great to be part
great part of that and do that in
torington uh only achieved average
grades at school uh I was a bit lazy I
think um but I was entrusted with
responsibility from an early age in my
career and I this thing keeps coming
back to me I believe really really
believe that everyone learns at their
own pace and the and the education
system that we have doesn't necessarily
work for
everybody uh while this was a
disadvantage in schools I think we've
got to be lucky we have seen in petrock
college the amount of effort that they
are doing to take on children that
haven't hit their gcsc requirements and
then they've got two years to bring them
out so they get sort of decent you know
a Ser D level qualification in in master
Eng English so although Bill and Tom not
here today from what I've seen from the
work we do with them I think I take my
he to them um I was fortunate when I was
at uh pet College back in the day over
30 years ago that I had some inspiring
lecturers and and they really let my
imagination I was able to come out with
hnc in electronics after four years of
study so I think I think pet rock is a a
really vital Cog in in in all of these
things that that we've got to do and
what we want to do moving forward in the
area you know and thanks thanks Reed to
the work that Pedro are doing I mean
they now got the the bones of a
University Center there so 30 years ago
the dream of being able to do a degree
locally in Northern Devon just wouldn't
have been a
reality I me incredibly fortunate so the
the culture we have in our business is
very much about um learning continued
lifelong learning and obviously great
thing about doing an apprenticeship is
you're not paying for your education and
you're getting paid and I've got a bit
that did appeal to me um so I've been
lucky I did a part-time degree in
electronics at University West of
England back in the 90s and then
recently I finished a master's in
Business Administration at hle business
school so I think this just shows how
far you can go uh with an approach
towards working earning and learning and
and really you know it's really hard
getting
and building businesses in our area and
uh we are relying on people at the end
of the day and we need people to come in
and it's not just about qualification
it's about that rounded person and I
think that's what is important about
appr ships and that's what what what
what really brings so this desire I
guess for me from was really to make it
to try and find out how can you actually
make a difference so I was I took on the
role of chair for the nor Deon economy
Innovation skills Action Group last year
is part of the north Deon Futures board
and that was really fueled by a a
passion for me and a frustration that I
that really as a region we've really got
much more to offer and I hear a lot of
businesses moaning about it and I
thought well actually now it's actually
us on us as businesses we've got to take
responsibility and do a better job at
promoting what all these great
opportunities are available in
torage um so that the Next Generation
can really grasp those things and it's
not it's not just for for for younger
people it's for people of all ages uh to
continue education and embark on their
new careers we've just got some you know
fantastic things going on in our area um
I mean the very fact we're part of a
worldwide Network um for this UNESCO
biosphere is pretty special in the first
in the first instance but with some of
the
you know stats I know it's Northern
Devon you know 15% of our medicine that
are produced in for prescriptions in the
UK are made in our
area and we've got these great new work
coming out from from har wal in the
shipyard te Maritime projects the work
that Chris has been doing and I think
you know Co has changed things in a
sense in that opportunities are
available probably more so to people in
our area so whether it's coding making
car caring or developing for this new
world I think the future is bright um
but there are some real challenges and
um I would talk a little bit about now
our business um cmtg so we take
on uh three apprenticeships apprentices
from school age uh each year and we also
take on in this case we've taken on two
um apprentic ships and put them on a
graduate graduate apprenticeship
scheme so they they're vital to our
business so 40% of our Workforce in is
greater than that have come through
apprenticeship schemes have going on to
you know to to all aspects of the
business so as we've grown as a business
we we we can cover things like
engineering development manufacturing
Marketing sales account County all these
things I think I think the the guys were
explaining that from from their their
business as well
earlier and that learning doesn't stop
so I'm sure Chris will touch on in a
minute you know one of the challenges we
face in torage is
that we do have a good number of
apprenticeships but not
necessarily able to have that lifelong
learning where you can get from a level
three to a four to a five and there
those sort of jobs that end up bringing
in the biggest salaries and that can
sort of uplift uplift our
economy um so so it really it really is
it really is a it really is a vital
thing but a number a number of our
apprentices go on to to study at
University and that that the way that
happens is that they'll spend two or
four years at Petr College doing a doing
their sort onc hnc in electronics or
mechanical design
at that point then if they want to do it
they got they got to want to do it
because it's it's a big commitment to
for the business to sponsor and put
people into you know higher education
then they will tend to go to University
of West of England for electronics
course or for software appren ships um a
university has a a louth university
other routs that they go they wanted and
they say this is vital because we we
need we need to to continually invest
and and and and train our our
Workforce I'm going to pick up now a
little bit on the questions that were
circulated for before today's meeting um
I'll probably answer them briefly and
maybe I sense that probably all the
panel would would like to contribute to
the to the answers on these questions
but um the question was asked about
gender balance um predominantly male I'm
afraid to say you know we we recognize
there is a need to have a much more
balanced gender in our business um but
it's not not really for want of trying
um I think it's a question really that
we all that we all need to to to think
about a bit more but we we do have one
one girl Emma who's gone on to win the
north de manufacturers Association
trainee of the Year this year so that
that was that was a good a good
outcome success rate sorry
questions
absolutely that um 31 appren is
currently on site and only two or female
and it's not again for for the one to
try um it's I know it's easy to say
historically engineering or stem has not
been a popular subject for women but I
don't think that's the case anymore I'm
not sure what the barrier is now it was
that in the past engineering wasn't for
men and it's not for women but for us we
we aim in schools for everybody it's
not I'm not sure how we can help with
this barrier that's my and know you're
saying we encourage it we welcome it we
do it whatever we can but until we get
that spark of yeah you know I've had a
couple of work experience work
experience this year that were girls and
when they left the door on the Frid I
said take this e flick because I want
back next September you know they was
really good skill Talent out there that
unfortunately we just can't seem to
interests through the gate um and guys
if you think there is Solutions please
help us we we're willing to push the the
envelope if we can do you think that's a
local issue I mean I i' I've seen a
number of things um Countrywide and
there's a lot of female apprenticeships
apprentices doing very very well I don't
know what the figures are I don't know
what the percentages are but do you
think that's just a Chris is shaking his
head on as far as apprentices go I would
say it's probably not what one thing I'm
going to pick up on is well when we say
apprentices for us both of us both of
our companies really electronic and
Engineering yes it's a predominantly
male dominated industry and that needs
to change but I looked at the
government's own website before I came
and just looked at the actual list of
their approved appren ships and
Frameworks and there's six pages of
different subjects and different care
paths than apprenticeship can be
attached to so I think probably if you
looked at all the different Industries
the balance may well be much more
similar but I think for our own business
is very it is unfortunately
very I would say would say we know pick
up on that as well for us I think
there's probably and businesses like and
and talk to and work with is that there
are probably two slices of resource in
our area which which we have to find a
way of giving more
opportunity into businesses and one is a
gen the gender balance I would say the
other one is um the the kids the kids
from disadvantaged backgrounds um that
don't have the same social mobility and
privileges that that we would have had
in terms of going into our into our jobs
that may that may end up that may just
don't see the the opportunity because
there sure as those kids if they've got
the work ethic and the drive they're
absolutely capable to do it and would it
be great if we could you know if we
could could find a way of unlocking that
because when you look at the stats in
terms of you know T all these sort of
things that we want to we want to push
up and and and raise aspirations so
that's yeah quite pass passionate about
that um so to pick up on your C Smith so
we're already working with maritan UK
Southwest because they're acutely aware
of the um gender sort of imbalance there
maram UK have a women in engineering
campaign that actually we're looking see
for next year how we can kind of provide
Roots into um northern Deon for that to
raise the profile um and interconnected
the crown of state are very clear in
terms of the floating a your wind kind
of opportunities that are coming forward
that when you're talking about diversity
in this area it's not just about ethnic
diversity within the sector it's also
about kind of um those two things that
it's sort of indicated there it is
around the gender diversity and opening
up kind of opportunities there and
removing barriers to entry um and it is
around kind of uh making sure that we
can support some of those lower
achieving kind of academic groups that
traditionally are connected to Coastal
communities I think quite a lot of what
I've seen has been um in in Services you
you hear
about the gender equality in the Navy
for example there's a lot of a lot of
female engineers in there and and they
already so I just wondered that's why
I'm saying they seem to be doing very
well in in certain
areas across the country and I'm
wondering if what we're encounter
encountering here is a is a specifically
local issue with stem with stem
Employments it's a very embedded issue
that um schools are encouraged to be
working and to overcome so that it's not
just a responsibility of the employers
as well yeah it may be I don't know
whether it's possible to to get some
numbers statistics on I mean a number of
work has been done to to try and
Benchmark uh different areas of you know
where we are as an economy so
interesting to see whether those figures
are available I mean that when someone
register on a friendship that they
register kind of as a national they're
on a register aren't they so National
Day the Govern um do you think there's
any influence um caused by the gender
pay Gap differential um you know women
generally earn 30% less than men I'm
sure that's not true of the your
apprentices once they've been successful
um they all are equal pay because
they've got equal skills
School staff members scho an incentive
to try and get
women on because generally speaking I I
don't know I speak for any other woman
in this room but it was accepted that I
was never going to earn the same amount
as any man doing the same job that I was
doing far from it it was just
indoctrinated um and that you accepted
it you took it as a part of the system
but what your you're saying your great
apprenticeships produce greatly skilled
people and who also have the opportunity
to do even more training um and that it
would be very appealing to women who are
frustrated by the fact that they're in
the same job as somebody else and I I
have a daughter who's a nurse and this
is still happening in the Health Service
um and and they they feel that they are
being differentiated against and they
just because of their gender now if you
can put forward a case for a brilliant
job where everybody is is on equal pay
gen genuinely equal pay um I'm sure that
would be a huge incentive to to women
because they're very conscious of the
gender pay Gap they really are no say
for for for our skilled employees up to
up to the skilled level uh there is no
pay difference in any way
for I'm not saying that within different
departments or different environments
there not if you were to compare
somebody from an admin road to somebody
from a shiping I can compare that but
our all our trade based employees
regardless of pay exactly the same I
think that would be a great um carrot to
attract more women if they look you're
treated genuinely as a highly skilled
person and you'll learn as much highly
skilled um um money as as your male col
and actually lot women would really
appreciate that I think you also get
into the glass ceiling situation I did a
quite a long program for the BBC on that
and it was women can go so far but they
never get to the very top if you look at
the board for example how well
represented what's the gender
representation on the board most
companies around here you know we know
the answer to that people get so far and
they hit the glass ceiling and it's only
men that get through it now that must
put off we're getting out of the you
know we starting talking
about but we're going but in general I
think that's a business should we
continue yeah should I take should I
take the next question so um so the next
question was about the success rate of
apprenticeships and the percentage
completing and meeting the required
standard um and how many lead to good
quality local
employment
so uh it's high actually mean in terms
of our business we we we've got a great
retention ratio as well
um say greater than
90% um complete their apprenticeships
and and that that's that's obviously
very good because it costs a lot of
money to invest in putting them through
the apprenticeship and it's it's a two
you know it's it's it's a two it's a
two-way thing and and that and as I said
before that this does lead to you know
to to to to different different quality
and different you know good skill jobs
and it it doesn't matter whether whether
someone ends up and really does a good
job as a test engineer or whether they
end up going all the way to being a
design engineer or or a manager you know
I think if they're doing a good job
they're highly they're highly valued so
that's what I put say that question you
had the pensions High lower than your P
yeah yeah um on an overall data basis
uh since
201617 the appren ship stocks in torch
um has dropped off um fairly
considerably during kind of 2019 so a
particular low point it's now an upward
cycle again um interestingly though kind
of the overall trend in TD um is
slightly down in terms of um uh
friendships achieved um compared to 2016
17 think some of the questions later on
might pick up on what what some of the
changes particularly for really small
micro businesses where where the thought
of taking on appren ship is can be quite
can be quite daome
um the the the next question was how do
you view the impact of reduced Public
Services on education and businesses
locally did you guys want to take well
it almost touches a little bit on one of
your earlier points of your previous
meeting uh the bus service uh for us
because of our start time we start up at
700 in the morning uh some of our
students especially this year's group
have
mentioned uh it is hard to get there get
to appor uh via a bus route if you live
outside of the bit of Bar schol Route um
a lot of them are around parents and
family members to get them there on time
so I do think there's a potential impact
some of our students live in pelli
or sheir tortin and there isn't an easy
route from those places to appor
unfortunately bord yes barnville yes but
not so much going from one outline area
to another if that makes sense so I
think it it has a potential for the
future for a problem for us uh
especially with those that are under 18
and don't drive or don't have their own
transport yeah uh they do rely heavily
on the bus service so
it could be a problem yeah I'd Echo that
ton I mean the wrote down public trans
transport and restriction of
accessibility so if we got someone who's
interested to come to work from
Heartland or or the other other way
maybe IL and they're getting to
torington and relying on the bus service
is not it's it's it doesn't work and I
think that really the kicker on that one
is that really affects the
families that the dis you know the this
is you this is family don't have a car
or or don't have the luxury of a parent
that maybe can can can drop brought them
in and it can't it's not it's not
ideal not
ideal and I think possibly for us if
they do live in those sorts of areas
that issue will be an issue why they
don't
apply um you know for some to go from
just toron which is Let's Be H not that
far away to get to toron to appor seven
I would imagine it is actually
Impossible on a bus yeah I think the
first bus at a Tor in could get you to
bord or could get you to barnable but
then swap it bit for it to come to appor
I don't think there's enough bus there's
only one bus that probably gets in appor
before so I think it it could deter some
people from join some frienders ships
depending on where they live so it isn't
I
think point on that question on no no
that
was um next question was what do you
viewers our biggest opportunities here
in torich over the next few decades in
terms of boosting education and
employment and how do we unlock them
so who wants to go first they don't want
to hear me saying the same things
they got to be honest with me I was more
drawn blank on this one um I don't think
there is any specific opportunities
available I don't think there's nothing
we can't put our finger on one solution
to this problem I think that question is
quite widely covering a lot of issues so
I think there's many things it can help
and I think some of the things we've
already discussed are going to help that
uh is there one switch we can flip no uh
I say I'm local lad I was aside from
being born in barn school which I'm not
necessarily not pro but the rest of
my entirely entirely Tor so and for us
certainly in the industries we're in if
you even if you go back to when I was
starting my apprenticeship the options I
had for an engineering apprenticeship in
torage were ridiculously high and there
were a lot of large companies lot of
mediumsized 500 employees plus even in
Easter water alone let alone in HW
worthy and some of the bigger industrial
Estates
outside that's what we need I think but
how we get that I'm not sure how you get
back to those or if we can get back to
it maybe as we look at now we should be
more in initative of what we do maybe
that's where the future lies for torage
I don't know if we can ever be
that big of a draw to these companies
again to come back I'm
not feel free to argue with me SP that
disagree um well P you wanna answer best
yeah no of course I mean I I think I
thought about this question talked to a
few different people about this question
I think I think it's recognizing the the
and building on these existing clusters
of small businesses that we've got in
our area in torington that that that
that are doing well I think getting the
basics done well and this is
underpinning what Chris is probably
going to talk about in a minute
obviously with the new opportunities of
of new new that you new sort of um
sectors coming in I think
the aligning with our strengths in the
southwest so I think I
think
postco you know work is work here you
can work across across boundaries more
you can work more collaborative more
collaboratively so in the southwest
obviously we've got the Marine sector
we've got the agriculture sector strong
farmer sector if we look at nor Northern
Devon and then the sort of um Advanced
end manufacturing engineering pieces
that that we all that we all come across
you know one thing that's happened
postco is that you know we've had a
number of people move into the area who
who who who are now working in the area
and maybe working at home or sending up
out
businesses
and I guess to unlock it I think we just
need to we just need to start working
together more in terms of in terms of
businesses education and actually we
come back to the point about you know if
we were living in a city um we probably
May each sh down the P at some point
after work and it just doesn't happen in
the in this rural area no so challenge
us all really and it challeng you know
we've got not only we got these
challenges in the rural area but it's
doubly difficult to communicate so we
kind of have to think about how we can
become better Community how we can
become better connected but also as
businesses and the public sector as well
I think we just have to recognize that
we probably just have to invest more in
it and and that's an overhead of doing
stuff in this area but if we do make
that investment and you know it's
time bits of money that can come from
maybe the leveling up fund this could
all help us become a more connected
place there huge opportunities down here
well if you go back to being in
agriculture I mean there is always
agricultural shows and and you know
that's where everybody got their designs
from they saw an idea whatever and they
meet together and then I went and got
myself to diversify and want to be a
pusher I had hell of a job to find out
how I can get the equipment where I can
get the equipment get that kind of
support that agriculture had and I think
that's one thing that you you hit the
nail on the head you need more things
that people can get together um and have
that kind of um
communication absolutely yeah definitely
Chris Chris I'll be really quick prise
um I think first thing when you look at
kind of the details these guys have
shared and it's fairly safe to say that
kind of we were fairly closely
together R smile on Tom's face
um 200 more kind of skilled employees
during kind of the next well of very
near future when you then start looking
at in new opportunities that are going
to be coming forward over the next kind
of three five 10 years connected to that
we've got kind of um the floating
offshore winds um leasing rounds that
starts next year we're already getting
significant sort of further interest
coming from the developers and that
again it's a very rare kind of month
that we're not in contact with at least
one of those developers so they're
looking to bring in again both kind of
Highly skilled um technical jobs but
also the operations and maintenance work
and it is crucial that we are thinking
about kind of the whole spectrum of
employment opportunities sort of uh
constantly you're then talking about
kind of we've had many of conversation
around the um energy cables coming in um
essentially to kind of Al discard and
then the subsequent opportunities around
things like green hydrogen green
hydrogen that is already seen as Future
Fuels for buses so how can we support
kind of department for transport because
that transport piece is
absolutely pivotal alongside kind of
housing those to me major blockers um
that we're
facing
um but throughout all of this businesses
are being pressured more and more to
localize their supply chains thinking
about for example their tier three
emissions so we're seeing these kind of
opportunities coming forward it is
around that kind of
localization and sort of building on
those clusters and sort of developing
real kind of regional strengths so we
can deliver so if for example we're
talking about clean proportion stemming
from The Innovation Center actually the
conversation that we've been having is
around how kind of business is moving in
of working very closely with Tom har and
wolf working with local schools but then
also looking at how they can be
manufacturing locally how they can be
developing those kind of local Supply
chains there are obvious crossovers then
to the agricultural sector because again
where is all the agricultural R&D in
terms of those Future Fuels it's all
into green hydrogen um so it's about how
we don't look to kind of go scatter gun
but actually look at what are our
strengths abolutely what is our heritage
but what is that Heritage is almost Next
Generation
opportunity I think the other thing is
that we have to look at infrastructure
um we wrote a meeting about a month ago
and we heard to our horror that one
quite a big BL in torington was talking
about moving away because they couldn't
get enough power to expand their
Machinery um the power cables weren't
weren't adequate we have the same
problem with it was actually one of your
neighbors I want to
say um the other thing was um internet
you know we're way behind
down here and a lot of companies rely on
that I know in in my industry which do
the TV and and film a lot of editors
would happily work down here because
they can bring the material down they
can work on it a small unit here and
send it back to London um we don't have
the the the breadth we don't have the
the
infrastructure so power and
communication I think is critical
without that there's no point of talking
about bringing more companies in because
we're already saturated our
infrastructure is saturated and that
goes on to transport it goes on to roads
it goes on to Railways you know the
whole thing but that that's pretty good
as
well
cson um I've listened with great
interest and picked out some key things
we were talking about transport right at
the beginning of this and transport
featured in perhaps some constraints for
people joining work
for is is it not time that we get
together and work together for more
community Transport that can get people
to their
workplaces they used to have Works buses
long time ago yeah um not so long ago
and Jamie Oliver was setting up um 15 in
Uki and he was recruiting apprentices to
run the
restaurant he had applications from all
over
Cornwall for the workers to actually get
to work for 6:30 breakfast start they
couldn't get there so he said oh that's
no trouble we'll get we'll get a bus to
collect them some of these youngsters
were having to leave at half 4 in the
morning to get into work because they
were pepper potted all over the place
which actually affected his
apprenticeship model in the end because
they were leaving horrendously early
they were working a very long day and
getting home and literally having four
or five hours sleep before they had to
get up and go again so the retention
there was
challenging we've got to look at it more
creatively because the socioeconomic
groups who haven't got cars who haven't
got access to transport we're never
going to lift them out of uh their
achievement levels if we don't offer
them equal opportunities for getting to
places and subsidizing those uh issues
we used to have things called breakfast
cups for businesses where uh managers
used to get together you know once a
month or something and talk about what
their key issues were and with
recruitment with Workforce with
retention um I don't know if those still
go on and maybe uh Chris is nodding
vigorously that they do happen um
they're not very well publicized then if
they do happen um so maybe we need
to uh explore that um I'm really Keen to
actually help young people get these
opportunities and get a foot on the
ladder because if you can't get
somewhere as somebody else said it's
pointless of M who actually joined
DS digs
digs possible I mean you know you look
at America and things like that that's
what they have they they you
accommodation
Friday another issue that we have in
this area big one housing is housing I
would say is probably one of the biggest
issues that we face when we're bringing
in
contractors and um additional Workforce
from um
um that we we get through agencies is
actually finding accommodation put them
in and especially during the the peak
season it's impossible yeah
impossible it was one of the issues I
raised when we were having a um
presentation about certain company who
are planning to bring in energy from
foreign parts and I said have you
thought about for your work
for where they're going to where you're
going to accommodate them and we've got
to think creatively about this because
if we want the developments of these new
technologies these new Industries these
new job opportunities we've got to
provide it's not just about getting them
there it's about where they
stay um and you know perhaps we need to
look at hostiles of some sort for
accommodating
people so um just
my thank you you're doing great
jobs really exced to hear about coun P
we have got quite a lot more
questions just you guys actually you're
the wolf and now the European border is
drawn down the IRC I just wondered if
you're affected when you bring tools and
refer B past and how it affects your
business no not yet no nothing no
nothing at
all we don't not a lot of travels
between sites like that we have look
like we said earlier on we're encouraged
as part of our contracts that we have
been
[Music]
awarded then the biggest issue it seems
to me for West country businesses is is
the road transport system because the
road transport system ain't very good
here and we've got an airport at EXP
UK um we are vulnerable because there
always cues from sort of um nilsy down
to Bridgewater every time I come down
and a three or three is a disaster so so
how do you view the future and can you
get the linkr fin pleas
because for us a lot yeah a large chunk
of our raw material has to come by via
road because of the the networks that
are available to us we're very tidal so
we can't have steel delivered on barges
like a lot of bigger yards with bigger
deer Waters to work out of so for us
yeah it has to fit on the back of a flat
bed so that does control how we build
things as well it's not just getting it
it does have a big factor on how we
build chips full stock not ships but
fabrication fabrication we do you know
General fabrication as well so the
structures which we have to get out of
here they don't float so uh yeah road
traffic Road Road's very important it's
our only M major AR and the rest of the
country and yeah people get to Spain
quicker they do than they do to the West
country from birming that's quite
FR I did 3 hours and 50 minutes from
Barcelona two years ago believe years AG
before for it
um the next question is about us as a
council what would you like to see us
doing more of or doing
[Music]
differently well I I think I think
getting the getting the message out
there I mean I wrote down I mean there's
so many the Hidden Gem small
businesses that actually are competing
on the world stage in tor
um you know I'm not
talking mediumsized businesses maybe
sort of one to five 5 to 10 um so being
able to help those being able to help
those businesses those businesses grow
is really important because they can
they can build those those those wellp
paid jobs I mean even the big businesses
like us I don't we don't appreciate the
businesses that are out there so we of
to bump into other businesses and things
well if only we' known they were there
we could have worked with you two years
ago and we've been working with someone
in reading to do to do something so I
think I you asking for some kind of
mapping
of well that that's you should say
that so so so yeah kind of but I think
it's sort of who who so who who can the
business work to give the networking com
back to Breakfast Club thing maybe that
joint working on recruitment I mean I
think even s
you know Tom and Tony tonight I think
there there must be overlaps of things
that we can we can definitely learn from
each other we're not we're not competing
and really competing against against
each other the same resources
um so joint working on recruitment
append apprenticeships I think college
syllabus is really important I think for
too long it's been a critique of the
colleges to say oh they just not
delivering for local businesses because
there still a business on up to it but
there is a requirement to local
businesses to actually get in and work
with the collegians
to find what what to find what what is
needed
now H wolf are lucky because they got
critical M and that they can actually
pretty much put a class through and I
think I think I've learned a bit from
what these guys are doing so you know if
if maybe four or five businesses could
get together and to match the number on
maybe Electronics going through or a
care or whatever it is then maybe we
could we could actually really help
write those syllabuses and get and get
more more what we want the last two I
have a transport we talked about that
before and then affordable housing I
think affordable housing is a real
challenge that I hear from all
businesses and and we we find that as a
real challenge so if I wind the clock
back maybe 10 years ago you know we
could if someone relocated and came to
work for us then it would be an
attraction to come and live and and live
in in and have a nice place to live
and a decent and an affordable
affordable
um way of living down in in sington and
that's just not not the case anymore and
there aren't the available availability
of housing that there and it it's a real
problem from from young people all the
way up all the way up through so that's
that's what I'd like to say on that
one yeah I don't see I'm not sure where
our young people are going to ever get
the opportunity to to bridge that Gap to
to start their journey of on the ladder
of Home employ or home ownership it's
it's l and we're quite proud of
how reasonably good our wages are
certainly for the area uh you know it's
it's as we call6 an hour is quite a
reasonable sum to pay for anybody in
this in this area you know a potential
30,000 plus salary a year and even even
with that in their money in their hand
there not a given that you're going to
be able to get on the on the housing
letter with that it's it's I don't know
just I can't see how that's going to
there's a big compound issue here as
well in it because you end up both when
both both parents carers then end up
having to work all
hours to be able to pay if they can get
on the housing l and a mortgage so it's
then and if you do get a housing
mortgage and Ladder then they have to
make decision about they can start
family so it's
pretty dire I think
really and when you look at the look at
what what Chris is doing what we're
trying to do in terms of you know boost
the economy in the area this is going to
become a you know a problem for you know
for for growth isn't
it I say I'd be surprised if you could
find a reasonable house in fordge for
under2 200,000 yeah so and we're even
our wages if you went to a bage provider
or something like that even a shared
ownership with government you would
struggle to raise even that sum that's
so I'm
not well you know that when we have big
developments and we have got several
very big developments um that got
planning per Mission around the ban area
um one down um near Norther appor one at
Aon was one wind Park all these big big
development but the problem is that um
they the initial stage of the Planning
Commission they're supposed to commit to
30% of affordable housing or rented
social housing but many of these big
developments in the past when it comes
to the actual building of those houses
which are L not first um they then reneg
on it and say they can't afford to build
them I mean and I have to say this but
torage has got a reputation of caving in
to Big developers so that they don't
they don't get their commitment of
affordable housing and yet you're saying
you really need it and of course I know
you do um and I think that's something
that perhaps Tores could do and that is
being firmer and more committed to
ensuring that the the details of the
planning consent are adhered to and that
big developers who do make loads of
money I mean um one of the developers is
made
billions last year um they cannot really
plead
poverty and they're actually they are
causing this
[Music]
problem is though what
is question different everybody a
national average but again Tor is not a
national average we've already covered
that one of the question question this
is considered a low inome that's not
what is the national bar that they be
asked them to reach is it we should um
because sometimes it would be rental
housing and not buying okay but the
point is that they have this commitment
to provide these affordable housing
which will be much cheaper than the rest
of the houses and they don't do it in
the end they they Ren on it they rle out
of it so you
know that's something that we could do
we could be firmer we could be more
challenging we could be more insistent
that our local people will get some kind
of opportunity to buy a house and that
isn't
happening we're also trying to get more
Community Land
TR
land more land available and that way
we're creting for an
enabling as I understand there which
would help with that
[Music]
toic yeah yeah they just um they've had
a look at the job description reviewed
that because they wanted it to be more
strategic because obviously we've heard
um a lot about we need to be enabling
through the planning system so that will
go out to recruitment shortly and we
just hoping someone with those skills
will will come because we've missed that
post for a substantial period at
that's Sor a good question um so so yeah
the next question was due to the high
levels of deprivation and
inequality Tores was picked for leveling
up partnership from central government
um we still have no idea how much
funding we will receive but how would
you like to see the funding being used
here in
torich I don't know who wants to go
first we don't know how much
I think there's also there's also
there's also a critical difference in
that one in that um leveling that
partnership is build yes as a capital
investment scheme it's also around the
Partnerships that can be created with
different government departments um so
that's where kind of and I'm quite open
about this have been already in this
meeting I think that when we're talking
about um economic and Community kind of
wellbeing we are talking about
opportunities strengthen Partnerships
with department for transport we are
talking about hland don't that's
controversial in the CST because those
are acknowledged um barriers um and
where possible to be working with
department for education to be kind of
supporting exactly this
narrative the piece that the piece that
I've WR written on this I mean so
investment in education um really comes
through strong from people from the um
on the economy Innovation skill group um
link between schools colleges and
businesses um drive up this for lifelong
learning more opportunities for people
greater inclusivity
um kids are never given the opportunity
to dream dream and M we realize that
they could come and get a job at someone
like
cmtg that possible for them it would be
great to to also look at the gender
balance and uh you we've got this High
pupil premium rate in in our area
haven't we and and I think you know that
that we can do anything to to help that
would improve in the deprivation in
quality
side
um I think I said before I mean we do
need to do something about communication
and you know come back to the city thing
I mean we would bump into each other
more uh what can we do to to redouble
our efforts to better communicate on our
Co Coastal and Rural District
um what can we do to invest more in
transport and and Communications maybe
that to to yourself counselor in terms
on the on the digital side physically
and
digital and I do wonder you know there's
a lot of initiatives going on in the UK
around cities and connected places
there's not much going on in the rural
side why not why can't we be why can't
we be a a guinea pig or or where as a as
a a test case to to make this happen if
we can if we can put something together
I think the government may be interested
in looking at that possibly marketing
out to people who've left the region um
that there are these good skilled jobs
available in in in in torage um we've
had a number of people come come that we
recruited um that grown up in the area
and moved away and then they come back
and and if they' known about us sooner
they would have come back sooner that's
what they've said
I think I think we've got some Assets in
the southwest particularly in in in in
Devon and being able to pull more on the
likes of exter an exter
University uh on their
resources um look to maybe replicate on
a smaller scale I know see with the work
that Chris has done with the Apple
Innovation Center you can really see how
that's going to that's going to work
it's in the right place far too long in
in North Devon you know there's not
being a a beacon or something that the
rest of the Southwest the UK could look
at and but now with the Innovation
Center in Marine Maritime we we we
finally got that and that does matter
once you get outside of once you get
outside of of the
Southwest and our biggest assets you
know top of my head you know if you look
at Tor rosemore what an asset that
is incredible you so what we've got the
glass blowing at dartington we've got
you know the elect iic skill digital
skills are some like our place sa in HW
the the ship building at Harem wolf um
the agricultural SCH core skills there's
a huge amount of skills available in the
area I mean I I those of us who've grown
up in agriculture or or maybe in the
sort of the Marine side know
that our brothers sisters families can
turn their hands to pretty much anything
very practical so what can we do to to
actually um benefit from those schol
skills from the area so that's that's
what I like to see us do um that's a
challenge isn't it how we do
it I think it's maybe awareness there's
all these things happening in here we
don't really know what's going on
they're all underground companies I mean
yog companies a classic example I came
up to you last summer absolutely yeah I
had no idea you were there I had no idea
what you were doing it fantastic yeah I
I mean it's just an amazing company um
but there's there's lots and lots of
things like that around here that we're
not aware of we're not promoting that
maybe sorry I know we are but no you
looked at I mean one the one of the
reasons why Pete and I giggled is that
we're working with North Deon
manufacturers Association and with North
Devon Council and utilizing a small
amount of our share Prosperity funding
um to create working with petro and a
local creatives agency um a makers
so Plymouth have a really interesting um
platform from theou manufacturing group
um to again highlight awareness both for
supply chain reasons but also for
engagement with schools and working with
the up to explore what we um you really
make a point there and it's quite
serious one because I mean and this I
hate to be bford Centric again but um
bford hasn't even got a chamber of
commerce I know that be dominated not
industrial but or manufacturing but even
so I think it makes the point you know
that there isn't really the partnership
and the communication but at that level
that would help to everybody to a know
what was going on and B be able to tap
the resources that are there um but you
know B hasn't even got a 10 gr
c c you make make an excellent point I
mean I I I do believe that I was going
breakfast CL getting the Chamber of
Commerce back up and running in in the
torage area is really important I I can
only look at reference points outside of
outside of Devon but if you go to
Somerset Chamber of Commerce is super
super strong I mean that they are very
very active in and around businesses
like Leonardo Weston's
helicopters obviously they had the
benefit of hle beat but you
know getting get getting the chamber
working and working with the council is
is just vital I think challenging you
guys and girls how do you how do you
deal how do you actually re reinvigorate
that as a
council should the the council and P
probably shoot me if I've got this wrong
but should we be facilitating more in
the way of um not face to face because
of the distance issues we've discussed
travel but using the internet having
webinars for on certain
specific topics about sharing skills
you've talked about maybe
recruitment
about uh increasing the opportunities to
have that dialogue um and you can
achieve so much by having guest speakers
like
yourselves um to give an hour of their
time and the audience you can actually
reach is is quite colossal
yesterday I don't know if you've noticed
on the news um there was a homelessness
crisis
Summit and
um 168 local councils took part in it
and that was organized by East born bar
coun so it wasn't a big organization
doing it but they felt there was a
really critical issue because of
people's budgets now if they can get
that 168 councils
delegates attended that webinar for two
hours and it is achieved I think and
will start things moving and I think
that's what we need to be using our
skill set to facilitate these things and
to work with you um earlier on we were
talking about child care and the the
difficulties facing that sector and
parents looking for places for their
children your Workforce if somebody's
got a child and they haven't got anybody
to care for
them they're not going to be able to
come and do work for you so you know a
webinar for and facilitate that to get
the child care providers together to
talk about their common problems and
what we can do to find
Solutions um and I think we need to be
using those mechanisms and is frowning
at me so no not frowning like it's I
think being realistic yeah this the
honest truth um we're a small council
with very limited capacity and if I went
around each of the councilors they'd all
say we need to be doing this we need to
be doing that we we need to be make sure
that we're both deliverable and kind of
targeted I would sort of get back for
example um over the last two years the
Marine events that we've held have
connected over 200 kind of businesses um
in the area now that's a specifically
identified opportunity to grow a
significant volume of high skilled jobs
where we've got a rout to act actually
having impact um I'd also say sometimes
it's about getting other partners doing
more rather than torage doing more where
we don't necessarily have the expertise
or even as in that case probably the
remit to do it um so
think yeah but I think with the leveling
up fund about facilitating and achieving
the four target areas that we've got to
do uh have projects for then I think
that might although again important to
point out those are capital projects yes
um so that would be kind of very much on
a revenue kind of well there is some
Revenue funded but not
that kind of volume can you describe
what one of those projects might look
like Chris um at the moment we don't
specific just for me I don't totally
understand what you mean by C so
leveling up partnership is uh we are one
of 20 in England the other one in the um
Southwest is
to H being done on a phased basis um
tbet being done on the first phase
they're looking at capital projects to
invest in for example Town centers and
Town Center
improvements now actually What's
um sort of the minister to uh sort of
his feeding down through his team is
actually they want to see those capital
projects that will impact directly on
the four metrics that have been used to
assign um those Partnerships so that's
uh gva that's average earnings that's um
skills to level three and that's healthy
life expectancy
now actually when you look at projects
like we're doing kind of with the appor
clean Maritime Innovation Center
actually that directly hits all
four um so it's looking at kind of
moving forward on actually what projects
we have and sort of the de like a very
clear any interventions they're looking
for kind of as we've been told so far um
two three maximum four interventions
that will make a considerable shift in
those metrics so what we're not talking
about is a plethora of small things that
will just make a kind of tiny or almost
unnoticeable gain but it has to
be large tickets kind of things that
will significantly alter the status
quo thank you it's kind of exciting yet
brightening yeah and and to we now have
greater understanding from kind of uh of
Minister and the sort of uh civil
servant team and then Steve is working
on clarifying that even further so we
can come back to kind of members and
kind of update but also it's now about
establishing a process with duu around
how we move from this initial briefing
through to kind of um project
development that they see taking place
in March next
year um I think some
we've already answered a lot of question
I think we have
yeah we' sort of answer them through
what we've been talking about anyway
unless anyone's
anything they like to I just thank thank
you for this opportunity to talk to you
and I think you know there's lots of
things that we'll be thinking I wish I
asked that so at least you're
approachable and we can get out of you
and you know that's the most important
thing and like Chris is in for us being
counselors we go to Chris to say oh wa I
thought about this you know some way of
doing it whatever so we have got a bit
of U our council is proactive and and
and that's that that my opinion is very
good yeah we really appreciate you
coming in and
taking likewise it's it's nice to nice
to to meet you all and have the
opportunity to talk about these things
so thank you very much
there any sort of actions that Council
want to take out
this one for me today let's be part part
the prime minister's meeting about
artificial
intelligence is it going to affect any
of our businesses and is there any
chance of artificial intelligence taking
over at
carage
I think you'd be surprised already
around kind of some of the uh businesses
using um machine learning and artificial
intelligence kind of already within
their operations and does cmtg I think
it's very easy to kind of throw out
Catal terms around artificial
intelligence without actually
understanding what that actually means
in terms of the plethora of tools that
are available out there and uses um and
I will utterly then stop because it can
go into Monumental hours long debate
that I'm not equi to talk
about something to put on to me I'm not
sure whether it should be on the forward
planning thing or the action this but um
and it's very jine to what we've been
talking about with housing and that um I
would like to ask us to call in Westwood
Housing Association I mean there's a
couple of other housing associations in
t but that's the one that has took over
the housing stock many years ago um just
to ask them
basically how many people they are able
to accommodate um how many is on the
waai they're waiting this and also what
the state of is in terms of them selling
off their stock because of course now
they can do that um eight years ago I
think they it was brought in that the
housing soci could sell their St but Al
in terms of what they're doing about um
uh giving the houses the renovation for
um insulation and possibly installing um
heat exchanges or solar panics whatever
they feel know we feel super because in
terms of the green energy and all the
rest of it that's also very important if
we're going to get houses that are
affordable to people to live in
who are going to take up the hope these
good jobs that are available so it's
only possibility them to come along
there's no rush with that but yeah I
think might already be
on well not on
the've so they're already up
there I don't know if they're on the
list for this year for 23 24 but um yeah
I think they're on the
list so I haven't seen one either the
list we've got on yeah no I don't they
on our forward plan for this year but
we've got like a larger
list so I've got here about looking into
the numbers and statistics on gender
equality about that in
work if we can at that again that yeah
that was
into
appr and we mentioned Emma Emma
yeah um the nor man so if we can all
spread the word about that
and I'm guessing that was in the Press
how long ago was it it's gonna go in the
Press I think hopefully next
week we're going been given permission
to talk about it oh brilliant oh I
didn't I didn't really recent oh really
EXC another one an action which we were
already looking at anyway is bus
services and transport and maybe looking
at the opportunities for community
Transport could we talk um pet obiously
W NE Mak it tonight yeah um I think
there was I've attended something where
pet were talking about working with
employers to
tailor specifically about the um app
ship about tailoring forces to meet the
business need um and whether they've got
any future plans for doing that for
other businesses and whether there is a
market for that and their plans for
gaining University status because to
have a university in Northern Devon
would be a great feather in our so he
could have that as an action for us
Petra yeah and they're able I they're
working on it I I um I spoke to Shan
this morning and actually both Sean and
Bill send big apologies to can't be here
they actually both have wies and hosle
actually so so they they uh they they I
don't know why sha was at the meeting
this morning actually
but I think he was regretting but um no
so so they do send a sincere apologies
and from uh I know the the work we do on
the economy education skills Action
Group nor down futures um there's a lot
of work going on with the pet University
Center on
Saturday um Petro has its gradu
graduation ceremony in Queen theater
just for Michael MoGo is actually going
to get an honor doctorate so that's
quite cool for uh quite cool for our
area as well um but so they are working
hard and we working hard I think it
would be so so good if we could get more
uh genuinely credible education um
university education in our area well
that would obviously R our skills level
absolutely um and afford people the
opportunity for study
more another thing I've got down here
every we be updated with the makers map
about I think we' be interested and then
we can share and spread that um
and whether you might look into the
webinars Chris
well I think our officers GNA be quite
busy with for a long while we'll leave
you thinking on that one um and also
what what do we do about the Chamber of
Commerce who should we contact on re
reinvigorating
that could we put an action speak it's a
de chamber and well tiny Pomo was the
last chair wasn't
he local Chambers falling away is very
much a national
Trend because uh Co and sort of the
postco period made it far more
challenging especially for the micro
community that we've got for kind of um
people to be out of uh kind of offices
for things like that there has to be an
added value rather than standing up and
just talking and just sort of meeting
where you get extra business leads where
do you effectively kind of create growth
um de Plymouth chamber is supposed to be
stepping up more and the work is really
about persuading them to leave their
kind of Heartland of Plymouth and this
is where for them as an organization it
is around showing them the value of
being in North Dev and torage as well
and that's where kind of these growth
areas and things that they're taking
considerable interest
in um Westwood ho have just
reestablished their Business
Association which has been sort of
dormant since Co um but they're having
their first
meeting this we next Monday
night um so you know again rather than
perhaps a chamber of commerce if the um
commercial premises in bford have
diminished so much that there isn't a PO
of people um perhaps a Business
Association
for trust me I've been trying to provoke
interest in it but it's
the yeah it's it's part of a bit of a
regeneration board one of the strands
that was um proposed was a sub group
around kind of um business and business
networking um there not the interest at
the moment because there's not the hook
for businesses to get involved
in you want to be giving something
away they have to no it's not just about
shortterm it's about you set something
up that is sustainable a Long Point um
and that involves a Time investment from
various different people and
organizations and if there's not the
clarity of actually what do we all
longterm get out of this
then you're setting something up on a
short-termist basis rather than waiting
for the right time and that is that
clear having similar conversation in
torington as well um but means it's it's
a natural fit rather than sh
I'm happy a few to get go home before
we're gonna discuss the forward
plan late you so
much shouldn't be too much
long
fin
than thank
you
[Music]
mind that I just thought they probably
get
[Music]
home um so
first we mentioned about the community
safety partnership which is yeah so that
looks like it's going to be squeezed in
um on the 30th of November at 2:00 North
de are organizing it so it would be enan
all and yeah so you've got
confirm yet yeah um so that we'll
replace the one that was postponed on
the 12th of October and then for sixth
of
December um we were trying to get a
joint meeting together with North but
we're struggling to get one Dentistry
because again that's going through the
[Music]
county
Pap think where I've read this um but
they seem to be bit further ahead than
we are I think North is still fighting I
think
driving behind that as
well yeah so I think the NHS have come
back to North Devon Council basically
and said that the scrutiny committee for
Devon County are where they report to so
that's where they would suggest soly go
away
[Music]
ands um and it's a brinsworth yeah
brinsworth the commun saf part um I was
wondering if we for 13th of March if we
could put active torage on there because
that will be around about a year since
we last them and there's of declaring
interest as a director on the board but
there's a lot going on and it would be
good to for them to tell us exactly
what's happened and what the plans are
for the future if if councelors are
happy so put that Mar we've got pick in
for April which at the time it's good
timing isn't it that was
Stacy we thought the April was yeah it's
up to members when when youd like the
moment they're really Keen to come and
talk to committee about the work that
they're doing so I'm pretty sure that
can be quite flexible on J so if we
leave that on there um January well
December lend you've already contacted L
yes so I have emailed lendy any this
week though so I haven't had it back
from them and obviously P able to make
it yeah I wonder if Petro might be able
to come them as
well and another one we want to our
Stage Coach w
we whe we do that for
[Music]
sounded pretty
urgent the transport issues
yeah should we put that in you can ask
but they don't they don't have to come
do they no hope and we were lucky like
today we had quite good representation
pleased that they were willing to attend
that's an excellent
presentation they have got a new turnt
AMS which they
published so
um I got that electronically so I don't
know if people there is a suay service
from clington which is
addition as reported at the last meeting
sh and I've been in corpers with the
manager Stage Coach there's going to be
quite a few changes but there were lots
of complaints and issues regarding the
changing in timetables rather blly it's
c a few points so it might be a good
idea as I said at the last meeting to
call them in
sometime so can we leave that Fe
you thank
you anything else the timing is that
going to be organized by North Deon for
this yeah two o' provisionally
o' yeah yeah it's not provisional
now excellent the the meeting closed
thank you
true